Володимир Путін у своєму щорічному посланні
Федеральним зборам продемонстрував новітню російську ядерну зброю
і заявив - я цитую: "Заходу не вдалося стримати Росію.
Тепер потрібно усвідомити цю реальність".
Як Ви гадаєте, нова зброя, яку показав Путін, дійсно існує?
Я не буду вдаватися в деталі щодо того, яка інформація
у нас є щодо типів зброї, якими володіє Росія.
Але суть у тому, що Росія протягом кількох років
вкладала чималі кошти в новий сучасний військовий потенціал.
Яка ймовірність того, що в Росії дійсно створили таку ядерну зброю?
Я кажу про те, що Росія розвиває новий військовий потенціал -
як неядерний, так і ядерний.
І це викликає серйозні побоювання, оскільки,
розробляючи цю нову зброю, Росія знижує поріг використання
ядерної зброї під час потенційного конфлікту.
Цього вкрай важливо уникнути.
Ви знаєте, що НАТО відповідає на таку поведінку,
яку ми впродовж багатьох років спостерігали з боку Росії,
шляхом найбільш масштабного зміцнення нашої колективної оборони,
підвищення готовності наших збройних сил, розміщення військ
на сході Альянсу, в країнах Балтії, в Польщі.
Наші війська присутні і в Чорноморському регіоні.
Все це робиться для того, щоб послати чіткий сигнал
будь-яким потенційним противникам,
що НАТО готовий захищати всіх своїх членів від будь-якої загрози.
Сама ідея НАТО полягає в тому, що якщо одна з країн-членів піддається атаці,
це тягне за собою відповідь з боку цілого Альянсу.
Один за всіх і всі за одного.
Головна причина, з якої ми це робимо, полягає не в тому,
щоб спровокувати конфлікт, а в тому, щоб запобігти йому
та зберегти мир, як ми це робили впродовж останніх 70 років.
Тобто, у Вас немає конкретної відповіді на новий
виклик, кинутий президентом Путіним?
Ми не копіюємо те, що робить Росія.
Ми не відповідаємо танком на танк, або ракетою на ракету,
або ядерною зброєю на ядерну зброю.
Але ми, звичайно, повинні бути впевнені в тому, що НАТО
зможе адаптуватися, якщо ми побачимо, що Росія діє ще більш рішуче,
інвестуючи значні кошти в нове сучасне обладнання,
частіше проводячи навчання. А також якщо ми побачимо,
що Росія хоче використовувати свою військову міць проти сусідів.
Ми бачили це в Грузії. Тепер ми спостерігаємо це в Україні.
Російські війська також присутні в Молдові
без згоди на те молдовської влади.
Така модель поведінки склалася в останні кілька років, і НАТО відповідає на неї.
Ми не хочемо нової холодної війни.
Ми не хочемо нової гонки озброєнь і не хочемо ізолювати Росію.
Росія - наш сусід, і так буде завжди.
Тобто для НАТО йдеться про баланс, про те, щоб
об'єднати те, що ми називаємо обороною і діалогом.
Ви згадали Молдову, Грузію та Україну.
Вони хочуть стати членами НАТО - це офіційна
політична мета урядів цих країн.
На Ваш погляд, чи мають вони реальні шанси на вступ до Альянсу?
Ми підтримуємо їхнє прагнення до трансатлантичної інтеграції.
Ми співпрацюємо з Грузією і надаємо їй допомогу в проведенні реформ.
Ми підтримуємо також Україну.
Питання про членство цих двох країн у НАТО
вирішуватимуть лише вони самі разом з 29 членами Альянсу.
Ніхто, крім них, не зможе втрутитися в цей процес або його заблокувати.
Росія не має права вирішувати, що повинні робити її сусіди.
Я родом з Норвегії - невеликої країни, що межує з Росією.
Те, що такі великі держави як Росія намагаються
відновити сферу свого впливу, вирішуючи, що
повинні робити їхні сусіди, абсолютно неприпустимо.
Питання про членство Грузії та України в НАТО
вирішуватимуть лише вони і 29 членів Альянсу.